President Trump is raising the
possibility of a military confrontation
with North Korea the president says
conflict with the north is possible of
its nuclear and missile programs though
he prefers a diplomatic solution the
warning came during a Reuters interview
yesterday two days before mr. Trump
100th day in office well as it is a busy
chance that we could end up having a
major major conflict with North Korea
absolutely newly released video appears
to show Tuesday's live-fire drill in
North Korea its army fired hundreds of
artillery rounds from a beach David
Martin looks at the US military options
against North Korea he's at the Pentagon
David good morning good morning there's
no doubt the US would win what the
president calls a major major conflict
with North Korea but the loss of life
and destruction of property would be
horrendous on both sides this morning
North Korean state-run television aired
video of this week's massive live-fire
exercise it shows multiple rocket
launchers and artillery firing as the
country's leader Kim jong-un and his
officers cheer them on it happened in
the same week an American nuclear
powered submarine armed with cruise
missiles pulled into a South Korean port
a b-52 bomber patrolled over the Korean
Peninsula and the aircraft carrier
Vinson came within striking range of
beyond yang North Koreans put out a
propaganda video threatening to sink the
carrier
but the fact is they would be unable to
prevent a devastating attack despite
such overwhelming firepower experts like
senator Jack Reed of the Armed Services
Committee said there are no good
military options for destroying North
Korea's nuclear weapons program there
are military options but they are risky
nobody knows that better than the head
of the Pacific Command Admiral Harry
Harris who has the power to destroy
North Korea but not before thousands of
artillery pieces and rocket launchers
could unleash a barrage on the South
Korean capital Seoul is the most densely
populated city on the planet
25 million people in a relatively small
area within artillery range of the DMZ
the US has Patriot anti-missile
batteries in South Korea and in the
coming days a second missile defense
system called THAAD will become
operational but those are designed to
shoot down guided missiles like these
they cannot defend against an
old-fashioned artillery round or rocket
isn't it incredibly difficult to counter
the 4000 artillery pieces that the North
Koreans have on the DMZ yes sir and that
is not designed to counter those kinds
of basic weapons and what is designed to
do that anything we do not have those
kinds of weapons that can counter those
rockets once they're launched
it would seem like this is a standoff in
which each side has the capability to
inflict unacceptable damage on the other
but Admiral Harris says this is the
worst crisis he's seen and in a crisis
all it takes to start a war is for one
side to miscalculate gale all right
thank you very much David